[Music]
foreign
if you were to suggest a way of learning
or to teach me
an approach to learning regular poker
whatever that means the type of Poker I
play with my friends who are like let's
play poker right
how might you think of approaching that
well given that you
uh
I mean you're pretty well-rounded in
your personality and that you like both
sort of human interactive things but you
can also nerd out really hard yes I
don't think there's really a wrong way
to teach you poker like if I was to
teach my my mum or something like that
my mum is the most
it sounds strange she's the least
autistic person
in that she is
so
able to Intuit social situations and
unbelievably emotionally intelligent but
could not she's like phobic of math
she's interested in sort of scientific
Concepts but if you actually try and get
into the technical weeds she's like
actually she cannot it's like she would
be
in arms with Molly right now just like
she's just she just feels she's a very
field-based person if I was to teach her
the game you know I would take her to
the table with
group of fun people and you know we
would slowly just like turn the cards
over and you know talk through I'll give
her the hand rankings and we take it
very steady in in terms of like this is
look how the way that they're acting so
they seem quite confident you know take
a more
human approach to it but I think with
you we would want to jump sort of
straight into the game theory to an
extent so let me apply some parameters
if I could just to allow us to cut under
an image so let's just say
he's really going to want to take my
money now which he will probably so
let's say I had a game with Jason and
you can pick the sort of minimally
viable period of time over which you
think I could learn to be competent
enough that I might have a chance
is it four weeks is it 12 weeks and this
is also not knowing how how good Jason
is I have no idea because I've always
refused to play what he's pretty good
okay great so let's just say
you know if luck is on my side having
some
chance in hell well here's the thing so
you have a chance in hell anyway if you
sat down and just stuck just gonna be
Jason it's going to be an entire team
well no but even if you were playing
one-on-one against Jason if you guys sat
down assuming you know the basic rules
of like which hand to be there's always
a chance okay but let's you know assume
the very Basics that you know what
betting chips means and whether you have
a straight on the river or not assuming
that you and I could sit down and play
ten hands and it's basically 50 50. who
wins okay let's say you can pick the
period of time of training right right
however long it is and then Jason and I
are going to play a thousand hands
exactly yeah a thousand hands
you're already your chance of beating
Jason over a thousand hands probably
with like just knowing the rules is
45
let's say that's how crazy like that's
something like maybe it's a bit less
than that maybe it's sorry Jason maybe
it's let's say 37 maybe 35. I'm going to
get funnel out of this
um
uh but you know could we get it so that
you are a favorite against him
eight weeks of intensive okay yeah if
you sat and studied all the charts
because that's what it is really these
days so poker is a note now that we know
the mechanics of the game basically
there's this thing called Game Theory
Optimal Solutions to different scenarios
which is basically you know if you have
Jack nine suited on this type of board
against a person in this position you
will want to check raise them 30 of the
time and check calls 70 of the time or
something like that basically there are
like answers to what you should do in
different scenarios with what
frequencies it's all about frequencies
and so now that we know this and and you
can run simulators to give you the
answers of all these fictitious
scenarios now it's changed the game into
a basically who's willing to
you know learn as many different
scenarios as possible and like basically
emulate them in their head when they go
and play so it's a very different type
of game it's more like kind of almost
studying chess moves I was just going to
say it sounds a lot like studying like
chess scenarios and it wasn't like that
even 10 years ago it was very very
different I mean there were some it was
more about you you'd sort of do
combination calculations in your head
and that kind of thing but that was kind
of the limit of it and honestly it's
actually one of the reasons why I in the
end didn't like the game as much anymore
I've been doing it for 12 years anyway
and I was just starting to get itchy
feet naturally but it required more and
more time spent to at the top levels at
least with these incremental gains
exactly diminishing returns in terms of
hourly because also what it means is uh
because it's like these Game Theory
Optimal Solutions exist it means that
there's technically this perfect style
of play that any one of any one person
can play and
the more the more people study this
style the more people are close to it
and so that means there is a ceiling of
how perfectly you can play like
technically if you and I are both two
computers that are able to play this
game theory optimal style we're just
breaking even against each other over
infinity over the shortcut you know if
we play for an hour whoever gets the
best cards we'll therefore win but over
infinity we will press break even and so
that meant that you'd have to be putting
more and more time into when a a sort of
shrinking pot of money essentially which
is why I don't now recommend to people
to go out and try and be professionals
in poker but I still absolutely
recommend that people who go and learn
the game because it is probably the best
way to it's it's the best
mini analog for the type of complex
decision making that you need to do in
life
that you could do and we're going to
come back to this because I do think
with my very little exposure to Poker
and having watched some on TV
and nonetheless having had my ass handed
to me when I tried it live
that particularly maybe an easy map is
investing and poker because there's
they're just so many variables that are
similar
which is why I think so many investors
are drawn to it and also give a plug all
in podcast check it out that's jaycal's
podcast it is a fantastic fantastic show
up I do think it is one of the the best
newish podcasts that I've put into my
rotation so
don't take all my money Jason eight
weeks what is the density of practice
look like is that two hours a day is it
10 hours a week what does the
distribution look like
to be confident that you're that you
will have like a 60 40 Edge on him
I would want to do
like 40 hours a week at least okay oh
yeah all right 40 hours how does that
break down if we have
you said eight weeks right yeah so
hypothetically let's say week one what
is the schedule and curriculum look like
so in the first week I think we would
I mean I would sit and
just run out lots of different hands I
think in person is better than online so
you actually just get to play with the
cards feel what it's like you get really
familiar with the betting patterns and
that kind of thing and we would talk
about the more sort of General things
like you know why are we betting what
what are we seeking to find here okay we
want to find information
we'd get into the idea of like ranges
kind of a strange word but basically you
know we're playing a hand right now
I don't know anything about your cards
all I know is that you've got two cards
out of the you know a thousand and
whatever the number is combination of
two cards that you can have
so right now your range is a hundred
percent
and same back at you and then as the
hand progresses basically I want to
narrow down the perceived range that I
think you could have you know now gain
information so I can narrow that down
and put you on a hand well meanwhile
giving away as little information about
my own possible range so keeping it as
wide open to you so it's about
maximizing deceptiveness sure while
extracting information out of your
opponent so I'll teach you about
Concepts like that and we would talk
about ways that you can do that and then
I think we would go and actually play a
little bit in person just so you get
used to the again to find a table
somewhere yeah I mean probably invite
friends over and we'll just have some
yeah have some games and it was so much
fun anyway those are the best type of
poker games bring in my card mechanic
and take all their money exactly yes
and then after that I think we would
start I don't know what stage but you
know once you seem competent and and are
able to you're able to do sort of basic
math calculations in your head about
like
okay well I have to call a hundred
dollars into a pot of 400 I'm getting
four to one what does that mean what how
many cards are there that I need to hit
Etc so these kind of pothole
calculations that kind of stuff could
you just take a second and explain what
you mean by part art calculations so
pothods are basically
you know like in investing to an extent
if things go well what do you win versus
how much would you lose and then how do
you bet size accordingly right exactly
or like you know let's say you're you're
trying to hit a flush and there are nine
cards left in the deck that can help you
say out of 36.
so you have a 25 chance of hitting the
card you need and meanwhile the pot is
offering you five to one well now it's
actually a profitable thing right you're
you're getting the pot is offering you
more than the odds that you need to to
hit your card so Matt and I haven't
talked about the stuff in ages it's
really interesting seeing my brain's
like oh find the words so those kind of
rudimentary types of math calculations
that you need to do and then as you get
more comfortable in that then you would
start doing more like combination
calculations so again like
as you're sort of narrowing down your
opponent's range
there will be presumably some hands that
they will have that are better than your
hand you know so what we would call
Value hands that they would be playing
but they would also have some Bluffs in
there so you need to try and think about
what the conceivable Bluffs they would
have given the sort of story that's been
told you know like pre-flop they raised
early so that means they probably have
stronger cards than than weaker cards so
you can narrow it down to like the top
end of the cards uh you know like Aces
kings ace King Ace three suited that
kind of stuff but then on the Flop when
an ace came out they actually slowed
down so that maybe suggests that they
don't have an ace maybe they have more
like nines tens eights you know to a
pocket pair like that you know weaving
together bits of evidence to be able to
narrow down people's ranges and put them
on like conceivable Bluffs versus
conceivable strong hands so that kind of
stuff after that
if you know you're seeming to grasp all
that then we would actually start
looking at the the solver charts so
these are these like simulators there's
this one called piosolver that was at
least popular in the day when I was
playing how do you spell that Pio Pio
Pio solver I think it's still the main
one and at least when I was you know
using it that was back in 2016 or so it
would take many hours to run a Sim
so you know you'll be like I want to
know what the optimal players with Jack
nine suited on a 108 for rainbow board
or something like that and then let it
run folks listening I have no idea
yeah there's so much dark in it I think
I need a rainbow that's actually
probably where we would start we would
start with glossary because there's so
many there's so many work terms the
vocab is is you know there's just so
much going on there but yeah so we would
start running simulation so you can see
and understand like okay this is this is
what the Optimal Solutions would be in
these certain situations because once
you know what the Optimal Solutions are
and then now you can you're sort of
equipped with this like really solid
Baseline of what the the perfect play is
where if you don't have any information
about your opponent that you can just
follow
and know that you know at worst you'll
be breaking even but you'll still be
beating them but then because you know
what the perfect play is you can look
for ways to exploit their screw-ups
because in reality everyone even the
pros are making mistakes they aren't
playing this perfect GTO Style
but you can't really know the way that
they're screwing up until you know what
GTO is in the first place so it acts as
this like Baseline Benchmark of high
quality play so we would sit and we
would study these charts and if over
that course of eight weeks I got used so
that you were able to like emulate these
charts to you know I don't know how to
quantify it but to be a good amount that
would be more than sufficient to be
Jason
um because he's you know he's not a
full-time Pro yeah he's good like he's
played a lot and we've only played once
and I was more just like bemused at the
amount of words that were coming out
well I was gonna say if his poker is
anything like his basketball his ability
to [ __ ] talk oh is actually incredible
that guy is world class he's very good
at getting under your skin if he wants
to get underneath oh yeah oh yeah